hi guys don't mind me I'm in a hotel in
New York City so a couple weeks ago I
got an email from the fine brothers
asking if I would give approval to them
for them to have an episode of teens
react where the teens react to me and I
was so excited because that's like such
an honor to be on youtubers react was
first an honor and now to be reacted to
is like a new level of honor however
then after I was like yes of course I
thought oh those are teenagers and
sometimes teenagers don't say nice
things apparently just went live and I
haven't seen it yet so I thought I would
react to teens reacting to me and I'm
very nervous so should I turn I'll turn
like this maybe that's better Hey look
how fun that looks I look like a fun
react right now perfect
let's watch this oh god oh no
okay teens react to grace Helbig Oh
everything is clenched Oh orifices are
closed oh it's Rajan it's a my ad before
this I'm I hate myself already
this is my reaction to me oh we got
eight minutes oh no did they say such
terrible things
they think I'm relatable g-baby change
your clothes keep at it
she's my kind of girl those girls
hilarious I didn't know I love her
oh my god she asked I love her Bob lips
on her chest when also kind of solar
perplex the shots have been fired Anna
Kendrick your champagne
a little bit like I love it you know
what you think because clearly I don't
know I love her I gotta watch more yes I
love grease so much she's one of my
favorites
she's quirky typically watch bloggers on
YouTube no no not type of a vlogger kind
of person and not typically but like
grace is one of the only ones just
because she actually keeps it
interesting how did you enjoy these
videos I took time for tea I actually
did yeah I dunno yeah she's hilarious
yes I love them they're so fun stop
inflating my ego I think that's awesome
that everyone like heads to this back a
creator can have chills big ass maybe am
i over Finn look at Lindsay little him
nobody's helped her up for like the past
I don't know 10 years do you think grace
has a chance of having a successful talk
show yes yeah hopefully I really hope so
I'm pulling for you oh so I really like
crazy YouTube comedian to late night
shows that'll show the world and
Hollywood then yes there are talented
performers on YouTube and yes you can
look there to find them so fun if grace
watches this episode what would you say
to her I love you so much oh my god that
was so insanely sweet and really fun to
watch but I do feel like I was was went
through an emotional roller coaster
Thank You teens turns out teens are
great I don't know thank you fine
brothers if you guys don't watch the
fine brothers skew I forgot to mention
that if you guys want to go watch the
full episode of teens react to grace
Helbig you can go click this link right
here well that's beautiful link or down
in the description box below and if you
didn't know the fine brothers do a whole
react series they have elders reactive
teens reactive youtubers react it's
really great stuff so you should go over
and subscribe to their channel because
they make good stuff and I'm really not
speaking from a biased opinion now but
their content is great you guys